let's talk about freedom man you see
this thing with uh with arnold yes
screw your freedom i shouldn't do that
impersonation uh arnold says uh screw
your freedom to vaccine hesitant
americans and uh that was it he was on
cnn for some reason with uh uh with
vindeman uh army lieutenant colonel uh
for some reason the whistleblower as he
admits the the general idea i guess from
from mr arnold uh the governator
is that with freedom comes
responsibility
and that in a pandemic people should be
responsible and recognize their you know
responsibility you know what he's not
wrong he's just a dick don't screw your
freedom freedom freedom is one of the
most important things protecting the
individual protects the system as a
whole decentralized systems work better
that's why america has been so bountiful
and successful and wealthy and that's
why the soviet union no longer exists so
no don't screw your freedom protect the
freedom and also recognize your
responsibilities but do it better in
this instance i think the issue is
we're facing one of the one of the one
of the most difficult challenges and
it's the threat of a pandemic from this
from the authorities to try and gain
i don't know
somewhat ancillary political powers
they're they're gaining so much by
exploiting this crisis
so the risk is
you know in during world war two we had
an office of censorship
loose lips sink ships that's crazy you
know we we hate censorship but what
would you do during world war ii you
never know if someone's listening you
might have some information information
wasn't traveling as fast so we do
recognize our responsibility but i don't
know i don't know what are your thoughts
on the celebrity stuff well like i said
uh to arnold i don't think he
fundamentally understands what the issue
is here is or he's misrepresenting it
it's not about freedom you should always
have the right to decide what goes into
your body um
whether whether a government authority
figure says so or not it's my body my
choice and and that kind of goes back to
the point that i was suggesting is the
vaccine is ultimately works to prevent
you from getting severe symptoms of it
and dr rochelle wellensky drove this out
essentially a week and a half ago so
it's there in black and white for
anybody to go read what she said herself
but the point the point remains that it
is a decision to limit the risk of the
virus that it poses to me individually
and so it's it's each person's life to
live on their own and we should respect
each person's
autonomy it's not like people are going
to be spreading the disease if they're
asymptomatic and they haven't gotten the
vaccine that that is really such a far
extreme outlier case that we are really
trying to
put some totalitarian system in place to
prevent extreme outliers it seems to be
like what we're doing did they did they
flip on asymptomatic spread
initially it's very low like it's it was
something like 19 to
30 percent of of the spread it's pre
pre-symptomatic and then uh i think uh
asymptomatic was lower than that this is
this is why i can't stand the
celebrities this is one of the most
damaging things you could do if you were
actively trying to get people to to get
the vaccine the best thing you could do
to protect individuals to make sure we
reduce the amount of adverse events that
we see in fears and to is to tell people
i trust you to make the right decision i
trust you to talk to someone you trust
like you you've gotta you gotta give you
know what i mean when you come out and
you bash someone over the head
figuratively like do as i say or else
they say i don't trust you when you say
screw your freedom you're like you're
turning it into a political paradigm at
that point right what you need to be
doing is if if i was going to trust
somebody who took the vaccine and look i
decided to take the vaccine because i
crunched the data i said states that are
have higher vaccination rates that looks
like they have less
percentage of people who are getting
severe symptoms it seems like it's
working so that persuaded me like i just
did my own data analysis and ran the
comparative research and i found that
okay it holds up it it washes so you
look people in the eye and people who
are hesitant are afraid to use the
vaccine and i'm not telling anybody to
use it or not use it don't don't don't
get me wrong but i would say you appeal
to you like you know i don't want to see
people get extremely sick with this
virus i don't want to see your children
lose a loved one
over this and so if you're at risk you
should talk to your doctor about getting
this because it could really save your
life potentially if they would just
leave it with that kind of sincere pitch
then it would be more persuasive to
people but when you interject the
politics in there and the mandates and
and where we already have uh what's the
fully vaccinated rate is 60
plus in the us yeah i think it's over
50. i 50.2 or 60 of adults i believe um
okay more or less yeah 60 of adults i
believe the last time i checked the data
australia was two years ago
yeah wow yeah and and so i i just
believe that um
you know it does help to for p for
adults who are especially over over 40
98.4 percent or so
are of the mortality is over 40 years
old um so i think that the statistics
bear out that you should get it you
should consider getting it at that rate
um
the issue is freedom but they're not
yeah but they turn into a freedom versus
authorities this is why the arnold thing
is such a problem yes because we're
talking about vaccine passports we're
talking about you know
uh libby emmons who was on the show uh
recently she she tweeted that
she doesn't believe children should have
to wear masks but her child will be
wearing a mask because there's no
options in new york city and i'm just
like
leave new york city you know like
don't make your kid go if you think it's
wrong for your child you make the choice
it's about freedom so when he's saying
screw your freedom
i don't i don't feel like he's actually
talking about the vaccine to be honest
i think he's talking about the expansion
of
the the surveillance state the expansion
of people demanding you show your papers
things i do not agree with
i think
there's there's a there's a mix between
individual responsibility and
responsibility to the greater community
and we have to find a balance and it's
not in authoritarianism making everybody
adhere to a strict authority now people
have to have to have to have some level
of you know autonomy
that that's why i was saying like the
soviet union they lasted what 69 years
fell apart
the united states couple hundred years
in the wealthiest most powerful country
and all that good stuff it's because of
decentralization it's because of liberty
right it's because people can challenge
the status quo we're losing that
i think there are times when you want to
install authoritarian you know activity
to preserve a nation which we did with
the polio vaccine i think or with
smallpox we brought up earlier
smallpox however does not exist in the
animal population other than humans that
we knew of so that was why we were able
to vaccinate and wipe it out so it was
an effective use of an authoritarian
vaccine
um
this virus seems to exist in the animal
population meaning that you can't
destroy it with a vaccine because it's
going to be all the animals that aren't
vaccinated at all times
mutations can occur in animals i guess
right and then the mutation is jumping
into that it seems more similar to a flu
which is difficult to you can't have we
haven't figured out how to you know
eradicate flu yet right so i don't see
in a thor it just doesn't make sense to
to authoritatively do that it'll be
booster shots forever i mean what's it
john that's third third shot came out
today uh for the immuno compromise but
but you know what okay good all right so
but the issue should be on the policy
front it should be
uh get your yearly covet shot but not
mandate not lock everything down i don't
i don't have an issue with yearly flu
shots it should be it should be like the
flu shot and what we're seeing with the
delta variant is sort of the normal
course of pandemics that we've seen from
1968 and
1919 um
we where you have this deadly wave and
then it gets the mutates into a more
contagious but less deadly
variance so it's very sort of a natural
flow of it that's kind of hidden with
the obsession about cases right now but
that but if you look at the mortality
rates and hospitalization uh legitimate
hospitalizations uh it kind of bears it
out um and what i mean by that is like
they don't go into a hospital for a
routine
checkup or something and they happen to
test for cova that doesn't necessarily
mean they went there for covid so i it
this very opaque data is is difficult
and they've made mistakes with it lately
but the point is that it does seem to
strike me the risk breakdown is like it
should be like a flu shot we the doctor
says i recommend that you get it because
you're obese or you have
some sort of health factors and you're
in the you're in the age group um but
mandating that children get it i don't
see the science there i just didn't
really think the mandates in general
yeah like cause the problem there you
the problem arises when
like that that venue i mentioned where
the woman couldn't go to a show because
her doctor recommended against it are we
really going this route where it's like
you in new york city you're not gonna be
able to go to a bar cause they're like
well then you gotta get a negative test
so we're gonna put a financial pressure
i i assume that i heard they're not
doing the free tests anymore i guess so
now what every three days you got to go
to a clinic because you have an
underlying medical condition it's like
it's like throw the ada out the window
man i i'm i'm not okay with that i think
we have to respect
individual autonomy and
well one thing that we could say right
now about the progressive left is they
haven't been hiding who they are for
since woodrow wilson uh they have you
know you you bro he brought up like the
alien sedition act it's or the alien
yeah the alien sedition act again part
two uh that basically made it against uh
against the government to criticize it
during war time et cetera
they have wanted a
technocratic managed society since that
period and what the information age is
in 1990 is giving them the tools to do
it and since everything is a means to an
end for these people and you could read
it in saul alinsky you know reveille for
radicals or whatever uh everything's a
means to an end so they will weaponize
the doj they will weaponize the cdc they
will weaponize every tool at their
disposal there is no moral
barrier that was in the place when the
constitution was written for them they
don't even see those barriers they see
the the utopian end line as a perfectly
little managed ant hill where they
basically just direct people to go in a
place and it's all harmonious and
everybody has their little food in their
little house and their little transport
and it's not polluting the environment
et cetera et cetera and that's what they
see and i you know that's where you get
like very intelligent people support
these sort of causes they don't see it
as authoritarian they just see it as
proper management of society um and so
for us you know or not i'm not going to
speak for you but i mean from my
personal perspective respecting the
constitution um in in individual rights
and wanting people to have their life
protected because they're given this
gift they have this agency they have
this
wonderful chance to
just
experience a life with all the freedom
and opportunity and
control that they have over their own
lives this is if this is taken away
then humanity is as we know it is lost
it's not
for me humanity sort of ceases to exist
yeah it'll be the borg
you know you know what you know what
you know this is it goes back to uh
colleges when i was a kid
and everyone kept demanding i go to
college you got to go to college get
that degree i was like i can't afford a
good college get loans why what am i
going to do in college you know i was
lucky
because i was told when i was in grade
school trust me grade school is stupid
once you go to high school it's so much
better they have these different
programs and you can choose some of your
classes and i was like oh okay
and then i went to high school and it
was the exact same trash and so i said
i'm out thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time